on Wednesday night PBS's nature series
will premiere Yosemite
it's a sublime look at one of our
nation's most stunning national parks
and it's also a sobering one as the
parks ecosystem is threatened by climate
change here's a preview but this is a
land of giants stone monoliths far
larger than any skyscraper and trees
bigger than blue whales this is the
Sierra Nevada
it stretches the length of California
and into Nevada
forged by time and shaped by the
[Music]
these forces carved out Yosemite 'he's
most iconic valley gave birth to
countless wild rivers and made life in
the stone wilderness possible
award-winning nature filmmaker joseph
Pontecorvo produced wrote answered as
the cinematographer for the film joe
good morning good morning thanks for
having me I have to tell you this is and
I don't want to overuse this word it's
stunning every frame the light is
perfect you're intimate with the animals
how did you accomplish this and and how
long did it take you well we spent about
a year in Yosemite and it was just my
wife and I we're the worthy and core
team and it's really hard not to take a
good picture in Yosemite to be honest I
mean and in fact we had to work really
hard to kind of live up to the
expectations of you somebody's very
difficult to capture that grandeur so in
order to do that we used a lot of
ultra-high definition cameras so we're
using a red digital camera and then we
used an array of other tools we had
motion control time-lapse units we had
handheld gimbals and then for some of
that footage that you see of the hang
gliding we mounted GoPros all over the
glider we use GoPros to get intimate
glimpses into Piko holes and stuff like
that so like a little tiny yeah mammal
that's related to the rabbits that yes
so cute yeah they're the smallest of the
rabbit family yeah they're pretty cute
yeah we use blinds to like that one
there it's amazing what you got when we
talk about climate change we often talk
about it in the abstract but you sort of
got a first-hand glimpse into a changing
ecosystem tell us what you saw yeah so
we were there at the height of the
drought and that's where we're a hundred
million trees have died you know across
California and a lot of that right in
the Sierra Nevada so you know water
became central to our story and you know
I think you know when we think about
climate change we often think about the
Arctic yeah just in places and the whole
purpose of this film was to bring it
home so we could think about how climate
change is affecting our parts in our
backyard and you know somebody is in the
backyard of a you know very large
populated state so you know so I think
one of the challenges moving ahead will
be how we think about national
parks you know Ark force the composition
of the force is going to change you know
we have a hundred million trees dead and
they're not coming back so it's not
reversible class not it's not reversible
well and if people are thinking that
this is oh it's a pretty place and
animals but it doesn't really affect me
they're wrong the snowpack their
supplies 30 percent of California's
water correct
correct yeah in fact 60 percent of all
of California's water comes from the
Sierra Nevada and 30 to 40 percent of
that it's just snow and so as climate
change progresses that snowpack is going
to diminish it's kind of dwindle and
that means just less water for
agriculture for drinking I think with
everything that's going on in California
right now with all the flooding it's
easy to forget about what happened I was
gonna ask you do you think that's making
a difference or do you think this is
just an absolutely I mean you know I
mean replenishing that though that water
supply was vital all right but in but
this is just a blip on the radar it's
really hard to talk about climate change
on a season by sea yeah the long term
big picture kind of starvation you have
to think about it generationally you
also shot in a Sequoia and Kings Canyon
National Parks tell us a little bit
about that and what it is like to
actually be in the wilderness for an
extended period of time working on
projects like this yeah it's an
incredible experience well first of all
Yosemite itself is a thousands over a
thousand square miles and 90% of that is
designated wilderness Wow so you know
you're talking a huge area to cover and
Sequoia is king canyon is also I think
another thousand square miles so it's a
massive area and when you're out there
it's you just have to be prepared for an
extended period of time
Power Bars but yeah take a lot of power
bars and in fact one time we actually
didn't have enough food with us we're
always balancing the amount of equipment
we're taking versus how much food we're
taking we're out there trying to film
Sierra bighorn sheep and they're very
difficult to find and at one point we
just ran out of food and we were down to
I think like a couple of beef jerky
slices that we like diced up all we
could boil did you get this you did we
did in the end we actually found the
Sheep what I mean there are so many
amazing moments throughout with with the
Sequoias and with the hang-gliding and
the the guys who were climbing El Cap
which you had to do to get that
but I thought you ended it so perfectly
because your theme is about how
interrelated water is with that area and
you ended it with the ten minutes each
year that that people can have this one
site that is just stunning to see you
want to talk about that a little bit
yeah that's the fire fall
it's where horsetail falls is
illuminated it's a very narrow window of
time you're really talking about a week
where you can really capture this event
and just as the Sun sets that hits the
waterfall and it just glows like this
ribbon of red fire and it's quite
amazing it's amazing phenomena and it's
something that these photographers there
have been trying to capture for years
but because of the drought
it just hadn't happened water hasn't POW
yeah it gave me chills when I saw it and
I thought it was a really appropriate
way - yeah lovely film Joe thank you so
much